uh just let's bring you the latest
before we bring you any other stories
and we are hearing in more detail about
an incident that as is developing in the
northeast of Thailand the latest we are
hearing is that there has been a mass
shooting at a child's daycare center so
that's a child's daycare center in North
Eastern Thailand and I'm hearing that at
least 31 people
31 people have been killed at that
child's daycare center that according to
local police via the Reuters news agency
uh the prime minister in Thailand has
alerted all agencies to take action and
apprehend the culprit that according to
a government spokesperson uh the rate of
gun ownership in Thailand is high
compared with other countries in the
region and we've seen a mass shooting
and they are you know relatively rare
nevertheless in this part of the world
particularly in Thailand but we are
hearing that at least 31 people have
died in a child's daycare center in
Thailand uh the police think were being
told by the Reuters news agency that the
gunman is an ex-police officer no idea
what on Earth is happening there but we
are being told that there is a Manhunt
underway we're hearing there also from
the prime minister's office saying that
all agencies must take action and
apprehend the culprit at the earliest
opportunity we can only assume given
that it's a child care center 31 people
having died we have to be very concerned
about any of the youngsters that may
have been in that Childcare Center at
the time we do of course have a
correspondent on the ground and we will
bring you that as soon as we can confirm
any further information for you but what
we do know at this stage is that there
has been a mass shooting at a child's
daycare center in northeastern Thailand
the prime minister is calling on all
agencies to act immediately to apprehend
the gunman reportedly who is a former
police officer that according to the
Reuters news agency we'll get more
information and we will update you as
soon as we possibly can
terrible news coming out of Thailand
this morning around about eight hours
ahead of us we'll find out what we can
and update you as soon as we can